What is first past the post?
You may hear this term a lot during your election year
and this refers to the voting
system we have here in the UK for our general election.
In first past the post voting,
the winning candidate is selected by having the most
votes out of any individual candidates,
even if they don't get the majority.
First pass the post is not about opposition,
as many suggested that proportional representation
may be a fair away for the country
to establish and structure its government.
Based on a proportional representational system,
parties will be voted for by the electorate
and then they would take the amount of seats
proportionate to the amount of votes they receive.
However, the system's unlikely to change
as whoever's in power got there by first pass the post.
Despite its perceived force,
this is the way the UK has voted for centuries.
And now I hope you don't have to ask anymore.